it smells delicious it really does smell
delicious
with tasting rooms set to open their
doors again at california wineries
it's time to raise a toast but for the
70 billion
u.s wine industry this
[Music]
is the clinking of glass that matters
most that's the sound of volume
scale diversification
if you can hear all that as a wine
company maybe you have what it takes to
attempt an ipo
but here's the thing no california
winery has dared to go public in more
than two decades
and for good reason robert mundavi vowed
to make a great wine for every american
table
iconic robert mondavi winery went public
in 1993
before becoming a cautionary tale for
california's wine industry
famous for their family disputes the
mondavi sold their company to
constellation brands in 2004
some bad investments and a falling stock
price had a lot to do with that
but michael mondavi said other factors
were also at play
the mondaves would have preferred not to
sell but the family saw it
as an opportunity they came just at the
right time today
no mondavi family member is involved
with the mondavi wine label
20 years ago the the folks that went
public at the time were
were single focused and then you swirl
it enter terry wheatley president of
vintage wine estates
i'll let you sip it she's gearing up to
take vintage public
the second california wine company to do
so this spring
following duckhorn's recent ipo wheatley
says vintage which produces 2 million
cases a year under 50 different brands
is diverse enough to avoid the bad
hangovers of the past
almost a third of our business is direct
to consumer 38
over here is that big wholesale
traditional wholesale
and another third is is done in b2b
in truth it's a great time for many
companies to go public
with low interest rates and capital
flushed markets there's been an ipo
surge the last couple of years
who's got the pinot noir but wheatley
also thinks vintage is at the right
place at the right time
because of today's wine drinkers
although wine consumption stayed
relatively flat over the last two years
retail wine sales at stores spiked
during the pandemic
as did direct to consumer sales as more
people drank at home
i never bought on instacart until the
pandemic
i now i don't go to the grocery store
anymore so
imagine that we've now trained all these
people to buy wines online what
better time for a company to go ipo
that has almost a third of their
business in that leg of the stool
direct to consumer this property was
once owned by bruce cohn
he was the manager of the doobie
brothers for years and years but
wheatley's own story of how she joined
the company
reveals vintage's most crucial growth
strategy
this property was acquired in 2015
after my company canopy management was
acquired in 2014.
acquiring wineries wheatley says allows
vintage to diversify its brands and
appeal to different wine drinkers
wines like bar dog that sells for twelve
dollars a bottle and
and really right now the sweet spot in
the wine market is
ten to twenty dollars we've seen
consistent growth over the last several
years
about six percent in that price point
there are more than 11
000 wineries in the u.s and a recent
survey by the silicon valley bank found
that nearly half of the responding
winery owners
are open to selling for a fair price
with the pandemic
going on right now and continues to have
some of the mid-size and small wineries
struggling really just gives us the
opportunity to
take advantage of the acquisitions that
we know are in front of us
[Music]
having these multiple channels for
growth is a lesson some california
wineries
had to learn the hard way would i have
preferred that ravenswood
become a legacy winery sure
joel peterson is known as the godfather
of zin after helping popularize the
california varietal as the founder of
ravenswood winery
i didn't expect to be a big winery but
as luck would have it the winery grew
and it grew and zinfandel became more
popular
following the lead of mondavi ravenswood
went public in 1999
but peterson and his board soon realized
they couldn't meet the growth
expectations of wall street
and so ravenswood was sold just two
years later to constellation
this is the 1999 version gallo
ravenswood's newest owner since january
said in a statement that it plans to
quote reinvigorate the brand
so this was the wine that we made
the year we went public nobody went
public really for the last 25
years in part because
of the lessons learned by ravenswood and
mondavi
there's only a certain amount of quality
and growth
that go together and the markets demand
sort of
endless growth you have an agricultural
product
you're subject to the weather if you own
vineyards
they're very expensive if you own a
winery it's very expensive
those things are all dragged downs on
the balance sheet i mean they've been
trending like
in the fours and the fives so that was
that was a nice jump we had fires here
in the sonoma valley
but because of our diversity of sourcing
we were able to go to the central coast
paso robles
we can go to oregon we can go to
washington with the amount of
estates that we have we are able to
really
diversify in everything we do peterson
agrees the wine business has changed in
the last 20 years so
vintage has a shot of succeeding where
ravenswood failed
peterson says it also helps the industry
that wines have changed too
a lot of wines are really built by focus
groups the wines
tend to be more uniform they tend to
have a certain amount of sweetness
associated with them
but they've also helped popularize wine
after he sold his company he bought
himself an old vine vineyard that
produces small batches of his current
label
called once and future almost identical
what's different about them is
essentially the vintage
he says his newest zinfandel is the
future he's always wanted for himself
but he doesn't regret the past for me
personally it was a very good thing
there were times along the way when i
wasn't feeling that way
uh but it meant i was able to
help finance my son's winery which means
that he'll never have to go public it's
allowed me to
become a vineyard owner so yeah the
growth the process
the people i've gotten to work with it's
been worth it all